frau feldmann der regisseur maus hat
seinen film mit einer griechischen
tragödie verglichen in das
unvermeidliche geschehen muss gerade
weil man es vermeiden will
er stellt man es tut mir sehr leid und
das fällt mir schwer ihnen mitzuteilen
jahrhundert herrn feldmann nicht heute
nacht im einsatz gefallen was für ein
film
ein mann wird für tot erklärt dann steht
er wieder auf und dann nimmt die
geschichte wieder eine ganz andere
wendung und wir stehen vor einem neuen
nichts
und da hat sie die schauplätze eine
wohnung in tel aviv die aussieht wie
eine theaterbühne aus einem
existenzialistischen drama dann die
wüste irgendwo im westjordanland groß
weit und leer und darin ein absoluter
israelischer kontroll posten bindung zu
ihnen lauter trümmern
das sind die schauplätze dieser
geschichte am anfang sehen wir wie eine
militär delegation eine wohnung in tel
aviv betritt und den dort lebenden
ehepaar mitteilt ihr sohn jonathan
seiter ball
die frau erleidet ob der ehemann
versucht seinen schmerzen verkneifen
aber er lässt den ich wirklich
gegenständen seiner umgebung an seinem
hund und am ende an sich selbst aus dann
kommt eine neue nachricht alles war in
irrtum der sohn lebt aber der vater will
sich nicht beruhigen und der hat gründe
dafür
[Musik]
allmählich begreifen wir dass dieser
weniger von realen vorfällen handelt als
von dem was im inneren in der
kollektiven mentalität eines volkes
nicht zu tragen
dafür kämpfen wir hier dafür zu diesen
seelenzustand des staates israel was der
immer noch auch nach jahrzehnten nicht
aus einem kriegszustand was einen
zustand der bedrohung herausgekommen ist
und in dem gewalt geschichten sich
weiter vererben von generation zu
generation dafür hat der regisseur maus
bilder gesucht und er hat starke bilder
dafür gefunden
ein riesiger bulldozer der ein auto
voller toter palästinenser eine grube
tippt und zugeschüttet
ein kamel das seelenruhig durch die
landschaft zieht es zum auslöser eines
tragischen unfalls wird und noch
wichtiger erscheint mir dass dieser film
ein visuell ganz starkes erlebnis ist
dass er sowohl in den entführungen die
er vornimmt als auch in der weite der
landschaft hier zeigt eine ungewöhnliche
bild reicher und sehenswerter zumindest
sieben sekunden eine sekunde weniger als
gestern
wir versinken